hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean horror
Thriller film called manhole spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
somewhere in Busan a young girl named
songhi is seen walking alone in the dead
of night she is on a call arguing with
someone when she reaches a sketchy
street she feels that someone is
following her and becomes scared sangi
immediately tries running away but just
then a mysterious person comes out of a
manhole grabs her legs and pulls her
inside this is already amazing sometime
later she wakes up inside a strange room
which is completely dark like most of
the scenes in this movie song Yee tries
sneaking out of the place when suddenly
a feral boy grabs her legs he appears to
be mute and is chained to the wall it is
evident that he was also kidnapped and
brought here a long time ago
unfortunately the commotional arms the
kidnapper in the other room he is
revealed to be a mentally unstable Man
Named Sue Chul who is abandoned by his
family long ago he quickly confronts
song Yi and ties her to a chair the
little girl pleads to be released but
suitual instead cuts her hair saying
they will be together from now on follow
doing this we were introduced to a 14
year old girl named Sue Jung who appears
to be mute and deaf her parents passed
away a few years ago and now she is
living with her elder sister yoncio the
latter is about to return from her night
shift so she video calls sujang and asks
her to close all the doors and wait for
her here we get to know that the city
has been plagued with several kidnapping
cases as of late putting the residents
on high alert unfortunately sujang is
unaware of all this and she is too
impatient to wait at home so she heads
to the bus stop and waits for her sister
there after a while heancio finally
arrives and is angry to find sujung
there she chastises her in Sign Language
explaining that bad people roam the city
at night this makes the little girl cry
prompting yancio to hug her tightly
shortly after as they walk away suture
watches them via the CCTV cameras he has
installed everywhere several days passed
by and when the missing girl song He's
whereabouts are still unknown her father
Zhong ho decides to take matters into
his own hands a taxi driver by fashion
he wanders around the city and tries to
distribute leaflets of his missing
daughter most of the people simply
ignore him and the ones that take the
leaflets either throw them away or wipe
their noses with them in the next scene
yancio is celebrating her birthday at
home her sisters brought a lovely cake
for her and in return she gives sujang a
packet of chocolates in the basement the
kidnapper is also brought out a cake
turns out it is also the victim song
Yi's birthday after blowing out the
candles he tries to feed her some cake
but she refuses she simply says my
father will find you soon hearing the
word father suitual becomes infuriated
and he shouts at the girl to remain
silent ah so his dad is responsible for
his fascination with manholes then in a
flashback it is revealed that his
parents didn't abandon him his father
was an alcoholic who one day burned the
whole house killing everyone inside Sue
Chul somehow managed to get away but the
loss of his family spiraled him into
depression so to cope with the tragedy
he started killing people secretly who
needs their therapy he then built a
well-structured hideout inside the
depths of the sewers which acts as the
perfect place to continue his crimes and
hide from the outside world meanwhile
jung-ho heads to the police station to
ask about his daughter's investigation
status of course the cops ask him to
stay patient but Jong ho knows that
every passing Day means that his chances
of seeing his daughter are getting
Slimmer so he starts shouting at the
cops and causes a scene the commotion
draws the attention of a senior cop Kim
and as soon as he sees Jung Ho he is
taken aback it turns out that the two
have been friends since childhood that
night they head to jung-ho's place to
discuss the matter over drinks Kim has
one too many which causes him to fall
asleep no doubt earning him a vote of
confidence from the terrified father
taking advantage of the opportunity
jung-ho steals his flash drive which has
access to all the CCTV cameras in the
area he then inspects them carefully and
finally gets some Clues regarding his
daughter's whereabouts after a while
when Kim finally wakes up he is angry to
learn that his USB drive and gun have
been stolen he searches for his friend
through throughout the house but to no
avail instead he finds information
regarding songhi's disappearance pasted
all over the wall this makes him realize
that Zhong ho has been planning to find
the kidnapper by himself meanwhile on
the same wretched Street a cop arrives
to repair a utility pole that has been
broken when he goes through the camera
box he is surprised to see a foreign
wire coming out of it the cop curiously
follows it and arrives at the manhole
where he also finds a lump of human hair
suspicious that there is something
inside he opens the manhole cover grabs
a torch and jumps in unfortunately for
him tsuchul is watching him through the
cameras he is well prepared and is set
an elaborate set of traps in the dark
tunnels soon the cop Falls right into
his trap and becomes entangled in some
wires like a bug in a cobweb suitual
then slowly approaches him from the
shadows and finishes him off with his
most lethal weapon a plastic bag he then
says his catchphrase welcome to the
manhole video
that night xujung again heads outside to
wait for her sister despite being warned
against it several times she stands near
the manhole and waits innocently
unbeknownst to her jung-ho can be seen
keeping an eye on her he arrived in this
location as it was the last place song
ye was seen as it was very dark jung-ho
believes that he has finally found his
daughter so he steps foot on the gas and
advances towards the girl hoping that
she will leave the way for him but since
sujung is deaf she doesn't hear anything
and just keeps on standing jung-ho
almost hits her but at the last moment
he swerves his car and crashes into a
pile of garbage the little girl finally
gets to know that someone is after her
so she starts running into the dark
alleys unfortunately she comes across
the real kidnapper Sue Chul who is
dragging a woman's body into the manhole
at the same time her phone also Rings
blowing her cover wide open terrified
sujang flees the scene and while running
she inadvertently answers the video call
from her sister the latter can only hear
the panting noises but it is enough to
make her realize that little sujang is
in danger yancio quickly calls the
police but they again ask her to be
patient it appears as if none of the
cops in the city are helpful at the dark
alley the chase continues as sujang runs
for her life Jung Ho realizes that
someone else is after the little girl
too he then deduces that it is the same
person who kidnapped his daughter so he
decides to save the little girl but
unfortunately Sue Chul gets to her first
he then knocks her out and drags her
inside the manhole elsewhere a worried
yanco uses a GPS app and tracks her
sister's phone to an abandoned house she
goes inside and finds several weird
objects like missing posters of people
and some construction tools disregarding
this yancio tries to call her sister's
phone but to her surprise the ringtone
is heard from inside a manhole this is
when it finally Dawns on yon so that her
sister has been kidnapped since the
incompetent cops will take too long to
arrive she decides to head inside and
rescue sujung herself on the other hand
jung-ho also stumbles upon one of the
manholes in the area and enters it there
he is taken aback to find several dead
bodies and mutilated Parts he
immediately calls his cop friend Kim and
asks him to arrive as soon as possible
meanwhile the kidnapper is busy
eliminating one of his victims once he
is done he starts cleaning up but right
then he hears footsteps of someone
approaching he yells his other
catchphrase you've just been manhood
realizing that his place has been
infiltrated he leaves the corpse and
heads out to take care of the problem in
another room the little girl sujang
wakes up and tries running away but as
usual the feral boy grabs her legs it
turns out the kidnapper has ordered him
to look after the other victims when he
starts getting a bit physical sujun
gives him a chocolate which she had been
carrying all along this calms the boy
down and he finally lets her go upstairs
the cops arrive and start investigating
the area suddenly they hear scream
coming from inside the model and when
they open it a bruised and battered
woman comes out the two quickly escort
her into their car but decide to
investigate more Kim goes inside the
alone while the other cop Waits outside
unfortunately the decision turns out to
be fatal a suitual soon emerges from
another mad L and kills the cop he then
slowly approaches the car and eliminates
the woman that had escaped earlier in
the next scene the Two Sisters finally
reunite in the depths of the sewers they
share an emotional hug but yancio urges
sujang to keep walking saying that the
bad guy is coming after them after a
while they find a way out and yancio
goes first but when it's the little
girl's turn suture arrives from behind
and takes her away this devastates the
elder sister and she wanders around
every house in the neighborhood calling
for help when no one replies yancio
takes the tough decision and goes back
inside the sewers once again
unfortunately the kidnapper is waiting
for her he grabs her from behind and her
way following this he leaves the Two
Sisters in a room and goes to his lab to
prepare some chemicals taking advantage
of the opportunity the girls break free
from their shackles and attempt to make
a run for it sujung manages to get away
but when it is yancio's turn the
kidnapper arrives and stops her he
throws her around like a ragdoll and
prepares to strike her with a rod but
fortunately yancio finds a taser gun on
the floor which she uses to momentarily
subdue him she then gets up and runs
away to find her sister in another room
the feral boy catches up to sujang but
instead of catching her he begins
assisting her in getting away it turns
out he liked the chocolate so much that
he is willing to die to have another one
meanwhile jong-ho who is also in the
sewers stumbles into a room where he
finds a plastic covered corpse hanging
from the ceiling jung-ho slowly uncovers
it and when he sees the face he breaks
down into tears unfortunately it turns
out to be his daughter's body after so
much effort and investigation he
couldn't save her and now he only wants
one thing Revenge luckily for him he is
in the control room from which suture
tracks the entire area jung-ho checks
the computers and after he finds the
kidnapper's location he rushes towards
him to finish him off soon the two come
face to face and engage in a brutal
fight both of them match each other
stride for stride but jung-ho eventually
gains the upper hand when he shoots the
kidnapper in the leg but unfortunately
before he can finish him off a huge
explosion takes place after one of the
gas pipes breaks during the fight this
opens the manhole cover through which
Kim gets out without even helping his
friend on the other hand the sisters
once again reunite and along with the
feral boy they try to make their way out
of this sewer they eventually find a
route but before they can climb up the
resilient kidnapper once again arrives
and takes them away this time he plans
to finish them off once and for all at
first he locks the younger sister and
the feral boy in a room then he drags
yancio outside and beats her to a pulp
as the kid's watching horror suitual
picks up a rod and is about to strike
her but just then jancio brings out a
lighter and ignites a fire as the room
is already doused in chemicals the fire
quickly spreads burning both of them in
an instant poor sujang tries her best to
open the door and save her sister but
she's stopped by jung-ho who arrives in
the neck of time the next day the cops
finally arrive and Evacuate the entire
area near the tunnel system there they
discover hundreds of bodies some of them
are sitting in the dining hall
indicating that the kidnapper also
dreamed of having a family unfortunately
yancio's body is never recovered she has
been burned beyond recognition in the
final scene as sujang is being
stretchered into an ambulance she
suddenly spots her sister's ring lying
on the road this makes her emotional so
she quickly gets up from the stretcher
and rushes to retrieve it at the same
time jung-ho also arrives and hugs her
tightly the movie ends as we get to know
that the two have started living
together as father and daughter what
about the feral boy and I guess he was
just another casualty of the bread
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching